السيارات ذاتية القيادة المدن الذكية
متصلة بالكامل بالروبوتات المنزلية ، هذا هو
المستقبل وسيتم تشغيله بواسطة 5g ، أما
G فهي تمثل الجيل كما هو الحال في
الجيل التالي من الشبكات اللاسلكية
وستكون أسرع بنحو 10 مرات
من شبكة 4G على هاتفك.
اليوم يستغرق الأمر حوالي 6 دقائق
لتنزيل فيلم ثلاثي الأبعاد على 4G مع 5g
سيكون هناك 30 ثانية ولكن 5g
أكثر من مجرد تنزيلات فائقة السرعة
ومكالمات إسقاط أقل إنها تتعلق حقًا
بتوصيل إنترنت الأشياء ، كل
تلك المستشعرات ترموستات الروبوتات الكربوهيدرات
لا يمتلك gretna 4G
النطاق الترددي لجميع هذه الأجهزة ، ولكن 5g
سوف يغير من اللعبة ،
تخيل السيارات ذاتية القيادة تتواصل على الفور
مع إشارات المرور
والسيارات الأخرى أو الجراح باستخدام معدات الواقع الافتراضي
والقفازات الخاصة التي تعمل عن بعد
على مريض بآلاف من  على بعد أميال ،
ستجعل شبكة 5g ذلك ممكنًا ، ولكن عندما يكون عام 2020 هو
تاريخ العمل لمعظم صناعة الاتصالات اللاسلكية
لشركات الاتصالات على الصعيد الوطني ، فإنها
تختبر بالفعل التكنولوجيا ج
يبني صانعو الورك معالجات
وأجهزة راديو لشركات اتصالات 5G
وشركات معدات الشبكات تقوم ببناء
العمود الفقري ولكن المستقبل لن يأتي
بإشارات 5G رخيصة لكنها لا
تصل إلينا بعيدًا مما يجعلها تعمل وستتطلب
الآلاف وربما الملايين من أي
هاتف خلوي  إلى حد كبير في كل مكان يمكنك
أن تتخيله أنها تفرض علامة على كل
مبنى ربما حتى في كل غرفة من
منزلك ، ولهذا السبب فإن طرح 5 جرام
في الولايات المتحدة بأكملها قد يكلف 300
مليار دولار